bonjour à vous merci à d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france donc l'ex
président déchu françois bozizé ne
pourra pas se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle le 27 décembre prochain
sa candidature a été invalidée quel
poids a encore dispose encore françois
bozizé en centrafrique et quelles sont
les conséquences justement de cette
décision prise par la cour
constitutionnelle centrafricaine jeu
madame je me suis fais un voeu pieux de
ne pas commenter les différentes
décisions de la coco stone elle sur
toutes les personnalités qui aspirent au
fauteuil présidentiel et aux fautes et
législatives
car l'ambiance actuelle et aux
déchirements et vous savez le show
droits politiques centrafricains laisse
présager à une tempête
si l'onu panda risque de se prolonger un
peu partout sur toute l'étendue du
territoire
mais tout compte fait l'ancien président
françois bozize yangouvonda représente
cieux régis l'échiquier politique
national
un poids vous savez tout ce qu'on m'a
qu'il a dirigé le pays pendant dix ans
il est le président d'un parti politique
qu en cas qui a une assise sur toute
l'étendue du territoire
il est bien vrai un sa candidature a été
écartée par à-coups cautionnait laquelle
candidature laquelle invalidation est
diversement appréciée par les
centrafricains pourrait proposer pour
les proposer ces il considère sa 10 à 6
mais ça un diktat impôts les pros
touadéra c'est presque un soulagement
mais pour les esprits avertis pour ceux
et celles qui savent analyser la
situation politique la politique en
république centrafricaine
c'est c'était prévisible puisque
le penser spécial du chef de l'état en
la personne de fidèle gouandjika dans
ses cours magistraux sur la toile il ya
de cela cinq à six mois il avait annoncé
et donc la cour passionnel n'a fait que
confirmer les dires
allez dire de tu pensé spécial du
président de la république et même ses
dires ont été repris en boucle par nous
parliez tout à l'heure de tempête la
situation qui vous inquiète en
république centrafricaine d'abord un
point peut-être sur l'organisation des
scrutins qui s'annonce puisque ce sont
des élections générales législatives
présidentielles le 27 décembre où en est
on alors on s'achemine inexorablement
vers le scrutin fatidique de du 27
décembre 2000 2000 va le temps le temps
est strict et le processus se joue comme
dans un mouchoir de poche
à l'heure actuelle les électeurs n'ont
pas encore reçu leur leur date nous ne
connaissons pas la liste des des membres
du bureau de votre nous ne connaissons
pas non plus à l'est les différents
bureaux de vote
et puis on se demande bien que les
élections sont fixées en c'est tout ce
qu'on va vers les élections du 27
décembre 2000 2020 est ce que ces
élections vont se tenir à bonne date
puisque à l'heure où je vous parle
à moins de trois semaines des élections
en les électeurs non pardon leur carte
d'électeur comment est-ce qu'ils iront
voter et ce problème se pose avec acuité
7 5 jeudi à le processus se joue comme
dans un mouchoir de poche et mais à
l'heure actuelle
la centrafrique est en pleine saison
pluvieuse et l'arrière pays de vie ex
excentré du pays ne sont pas accessibles
en pleine saison pluvieuse et or se
demande est ce que ray
le mans c'est ce que t'es trompé aura
bel et bien le les protagonistes en fait
qui sont impliqués dans ce cadre dans
cette élection on retrouve beaucoup de
personnes deux protagonistes étaient
présents déjà au plus fort de la crise
en 2013
on peut citer des collations de galles
catherine samba pense à michel de tod's
a oscillé dans les drom tour au pays
même si lui n'est pas candidat c'est le
chef d'eulex
c'est les cas donc il la situation
aujourd'hui militaire en centrafrique
est ce qu'elle est sujette selon vous
justement à une des inquiétudes
concernant la stabilité du pays
parce qu'il ya toujours ces milices
cette inquiétude françois bozizé dont la
candidature a été invalidée
et puis l'art mais aussi cette question
elle se pose en centrafrique
l'invalidation de la candidature de
l'ancien président françois bozizé
yangouvonda en elle-même ne pose pas
problème
ce qui pose problème c'est la manière à
laquelle c'est tout ce fourmillement de
systèmes qui qui ont vu look qui englobe
les validation de sa candidature et déjà
de cuisine lorsque sa candidature a été
invalidée ce que nous déplorons ce que
nous redoutons c'est la manière à
laquelle lé batteur d'estrade les
casseurs d'assiette du système en place
un sadorn se donnent à coeur joie pour
pouvoir le fustiger l'humilier vous
savez le commerce de la haine à verser
notre pays a poussé notre pays à un bas
de l'embrasement et donc nous demandons
à ce que que ce soit ceux qui
soutiennent la keller président de la
république que ce soit ceux qui sont
entre le l'ancien président de
de la république ou ceux qui sont avec
lui nous ne souhaitons à ce que l'ong
earth suspect soit bon enfant pour que
le pays puisse aller de l'avant c'est ce
que nouveau du temps maintenant presque
tous les protagonistes de la crise
d'hier ce qui en fait en sorte que nous
avons connus cette brune blonde
contemporaine ils aspirent tous à la
paix tous les centrafricains sans
exception aspire à la paix c'est pour
cela il ya les élections c'est pour cela
que il ya un engouement autour du
scrutin de 2 27 décembre 2020 tout le
monde veut la paix tout le monde aspire
à la paix et nous avons réussi quelque
part dans le communiqué de 2,2 de
nouveau du parti knk un iso a appelé au
calme
c'est déjà bien et nous redoutons alors
le parti qui a éclaté le parti de
françois bozizé juste très rapidement
cette question de la présence de la
minus kaki et la mission internationale
de soutien à la centrafrique de l'union
africaine en ce qui concerne la
sécurisation des futurs scrutins la
quelle est la situation alors la musique
a donné ses serveurs c'est que et le le
scrutin de du 27 décembre 2020 une chose
est sûre cette force onusienne a montré
un sa capacité à déployer toutes ses
forces sur toute l'étendue du territoire
en 2000 en 2015 elle à sécuriser le
processus électoral de 2015 et ça s'est
passé dans une ambiance conviviale
il n'y a pas eu de débordement et nous
osons penser que en 2020 elle fera la
même chose donc pour ce qui concerne la
sécurisation du du scrutin
que ce soit le déploiement inde et de
matériel
matériels électoraux ont leur
déploiement au niveau de bangui ça ne
posera pas problème pour la muscade
merci beaucoup à vous rendriez à joseph
mettez pour cette analyse je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes
centrafricain